hey guys it's friday again which means
I've got full awesome gaming stories
plus one to help you get games a whole
lot cheaper let's get going first up and
to get the sad stuff out of the way
Konami officially canceled silent Hills
this week and pull displayable teaser PT
down from the PlayStation Store the
highly anticipated newest installment in
the Silent Hill franchise will
officially not be going ahead in the
wake of Hideo Kojima's departure from
Konami konami has said that while they
intend to work on new Silent Hill games
in future quote the embryonic cell and
Hills project developed with Guillermo
del Toro and featuring the likeness of
Norman Reedus will not be continued
massive bummer and ESPN hostess at a
whole lot of crap about both eSports and
gamers after heroes of the storm
competition aired on espn2 radio host
Colin Cowherd said that if the company
ever forced him to cover eSports he
would quit adding quote somebody locked
the basement door at Mom's house and
don't let him out he said the world he
tolerated Donkey Kong he stopped caring
about fantasy worlds after Harry Potter
I'm not all that into eSports myself but
I'd suggest that while cowherd may be
employed to be abrasive and entertaining
he should keep his offensive game of
stereotypes to himself next time
and now we can cheap stuff or free stuff
as you find yourself with a subscription
to PlayStation Plus or xbox live
microsoft are giving away full nation FX
and castlestorm definitive edition on
xbox one throughout the month of May in
the first half of me you can also get
mafia 2 for your xbox 360 and then f1
2013 from me 16 onwards as for
PlayStation Plus on ps4 you can grab a
whole heap of games for free or months
these are either one guacamelee super
championship turbo edition race the Sun
hohokam and the unfinished Swan on both
ps3 and PlayStation Vita you can get her
hokum wake the phone and unfinished worn
while Vita will also offer up RT puzzle
game morisaki baby you'd be hard-pressed
to miss all of the Skyrim paid mod drama
from last week but here are the cliff
notes valve in cooperation with the
Thursday release the ability for mod
creators to charge for the Steam
Workshop products but after enraging a
significant portion of their fans they
decided it would not be the best course
of action after all valve said they
backtracked because it became apparent
that they weren't executing on the idea
in a way that pants were keen on such as
the followed up that statement saying
quote the feedback has been clear this
is not a feature you want awkwardly that
statement came just hours after Bethesda
posted a lengthy blog detailing why they
were enthusiastic for paid mods in
Skyrim at the end of the day the berserk
included our community knows best and
they will decide how modding should work
probably a good news there
and finally the director of Final
Fantasy 15 took some time out to respond
to sound complaints related to the game
demo this week Hajime Tabata took some
time out to address the issues as part
of the square Enix active Time Report
video podcast he pledged to fix the
sluggish camera and ensure frame rate
stability after the quality of those
features was brought into question
although he wasn't all that interested
in the complaint that Cindy's character
model was too sexy Tabata insisted that
Cindy is simply an energetic and cheery
young woman I suppose she simply also
has the penchant for Brighton revealing
clothing along with that Tabata said
quote she's actually not meant to be an
erotic character adding it wouldn't be
too problematic even if say she shows up
on the screen while your parents are in
the living room it's sad to say to
Walker and I grew up in pretty different
houses if that's ok let me know down in
that comment section or on my twitter if
you think esports should be on ESPN or
not and why this week on site come and
sub check out some fancy new armor in
Skyrim mods I cover off on whether
episodic games are any good on beaches
and in two minutes discusses the best
gaming anti-piracy methods that is it
for me this week be sure to have
yourself a lovely weekend and i'll catch
you again on monday
you